mud you chose through the life thing
being a great cost to yourself
to help start a war which want to help
me in it
hey everybody new Star Trek is getting
ready to drop I had a chance to see the
first two episodes early this is gonna
be my non-spoilery review it just give
you a sense for what it feels like and
explain where to watch it don't worry if
you're confused about all that but
depending on interest level from you
guys I will do weekly videos so be sure
to subscribe to get everything and there
will be a giveaway at the end of this
for CBS all access in case you don't
have it yet so I really do hope people
like this Blueway my expectations based
on the way they've been marketing it
they have definitely been under selling
this but if you didn't know this is
gonna be 17 episodes for the first
season its way stronger than a lot of
the Star Trek movies that we've had the
last couple of years already
Sunday what's gonna happen is they'll
drop the first episode on CBS proper
then they'll have the first two episodes
available on CBS all access the digital
streaming service that you have to sign
up for so you actually can watch the
first two episodes tomorrow and what
they'll do just like Hulu style they'll
release one new episode per week on CBS
all access so only the first episode is
gonna be on CBS all of the other
episodes will only be on CBS all access
I don't know if they're gonna allow it
to be on other streaming networks after
the season is over if you live outside
the United States just be sure to check
the Star Trek Discovery website about
where it's streaming in your country so
really like the important stuff first
you have two starships in this you
probably seen versions of the trailer
there's the Star Trek discovery in the
shinzou
so really the main characters are Jason
Isaacs he's the captain of the discovery
then you have Michelle Yao she's the
captain of the Shen Xue her first
officer is Michael Burnham who's an
equal Martin green from Walking Dead
she's been with this captain for seven
years but she grew up with Spock's
father Sarek on Vulcan so I should
actually probably also say that this is
prime timeline meaning that it's not in
the JJ Abrams continuity they just roll
that up into a garbage ball and throw it
right in the trash this is canon with
the other Star Trek TV series so deep
space 9 next-gen everything else it's
set up
ten years before the original series so
Kirk is alive in this series but he's a
young boy so you can see part of the
reason why they said it during that time
period this is because relations between
Klingons and Earth weren't very good so
there's gonna be a lot of war that's
what they're teasing in the trailer but
if they really want to they can
introduce young Kirk on the TV show or a
young Spock
they haven't completely explained how
they're going to address Spock having a
sort of surrogate sister because that's
who Michael Burnham would be but they
never really talked about Spock having a
sister in the pre-existing Canon they
did confirm this box human mother would
be a part of the series later on but not
right away Michael becomes Sarek sward
she grows up at the Vulcan Academy so
she's human she experiences the full
range of human emotions you can kind of
see the direction that's going but she
thinks more like a Vulcan so far the
supporting bridge cast is great they
have a really awesome looking cyborg it
looks like something right out of
Farscape it looks really trippy but it's
actually pretty cool and then on the
Klingon side of things the main
character is called Takuma is played by
Chris Obi you may remember him from
American Gods but he's a total badass
he's not really like a Worf character
he's more like a mixture of Worf and
Gowron he's sort of a leader to his
people but you have to imagine that this
is a time before they'd started treating
with the Federation in a really big way
so they spend a lot of time setting up
sort of the power structure what their
culture is like in a way that it took a
lot longer to get on next gen or ds9
but overall the series feels kind of
like the baby of next-gen and ds9 ds9
was really the series that i watched
when it first aired I was a little too
young to catch next-gen when it first
aired but I really enjoyed sort of the
space Western down-and-dirty feel the
ds9 had and when the Klingons came on
during season 4 that was really when the
series took off so the powers that be
learn their lesson they're bringing the
Klingons in full force starting with the
first episode they'll be sort of like
the main antagonist but in the way that
Star Trek weaves a lot of different
characters and stories they set them up
like they're going to be the big
antagonist of the series but there's the
Romulans there's a lot of other people
that could serve as villains the
expectation that I got after this is
that eventually this main character to
come would develop more of a
relationship with the Michael Burnham
character in the
Starfleet characters even though things
would sort of spiral out of control so
he's not a crazy person or a meme in the
way that Gowron was there were a lot of
good Gowron moments but by the end of
ds9 before Worf gave him the big
Smackdown this is kind of what his
character looked like all the time when
he was on-screen so they're trying to
give the Klingons much more subtle much
more nuanced performance the Klingon
Empire has been disarray for generations
but there's still a lot of comedy but
they're not playing it the same way the
other big Star Trek show that just
dropped is the Orval so that's basically
like a Star Trek galaxy quest show but
it's more of a comedy than a sci-fi show
so even though a lot of Star Trek is all
about the characters they also weave a
lot of really hard science into it
that's really cool so it feels smart in
the way that or bill does not but Star
Trek has been doing that for a long time
next-gen was a really smart series ds9
was a really smart series even if you're
a big Voyager or Enterprise fan they
still did the same thing with those two
but sort of the late edition you may
have heard about it recently is that
Rainn Wilson was cast as mud from the
classic series so just like Sarek he's
one of the other pre-existing characters
they're bringing on from the original
series but hopefully that answers a
little bit about what's going on I don't
know how CBS is gonna treat YouTube
content most of the big studios I have
relationships with so they're cool when
I make videos for this stuff but I
haven't had a lot of dealings with CBS
so if everybody does want me to do
videos for it just let me know in the
comments and just depending on interest
level I'll do weekly videos just having
seen the first two episodes they do
promise some very big things that are
really exciting so I think it could
actually be legit awesome in a way that
we haven't seen in a while and I feel
like Star Trek is suited for TV a lot
more than it's suited for the big motion
pictures like if you were disappointed
in the last couple of big Star Trek
films for feeling more like Fast &
Furious movies with Star Trek characters
in them then discovery will be a little
more your speed it feels like a real
Star Trek show the ships all the props
everything looks great and just remember
like I said this isn't keeping with the
continuity of the original TV shows they
call that the primetime line
the stuff in the movies is called Kelvin
timeline you can ignore all that and I
almost forgot
one of the coolest things they just
announced is they confirm that they
would be going to the Mirror Universe so
if you're a big fan of those episodes
they didn't say when they would start
doing that but they did say what
happened during the first season and
it'll be a big story element the cast is
solid Jonathan Frakes is directing some
of the episodes some of the other Star
Trek actors that are still alive and
able to do so have said that they're
totally willing to come on and guest
star even William Shatner is like oh
yeah I'll totally guest star if they
have a really interesting role for me
but once you do have a chance to see the
series just let me know what you think
of it in the comments below
so remember first episode drops on
Sunday and there's a giveaway for CBS
all access membership all you have to do
to enter just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I'll announce the
winner when I post my spoilery Easter
Egg video for episode 1 so while you
wait for everything you can click here
for brand new Rick and Morty and you can
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you